(steady music)
- All right.
Welcome to the Smartphone Awards 2022.
It's one of my favorite videos.
Y'all knew it was coming.
It's a bit of a tradition
around here to revisit the smartphones
that came out during
the calendar year 2022.
And then I like to recognize
and reward some of the best
and some of the worst that came out
and some of the interesting
stuff that happened
during this calendar year.
There's a lot, usually we forget
about a lot of this stuff,
but this is one of my
favorite videos to make.
We even have, of course, no spoilers,
but we've got some trophies
for the winners as well.
They're super nice.
So, from flagships to
midranges to budget phones
to specialty phones to folding
phones, I got to use 'em all.
I got, I have my own opinions
about them, and you know,
some of you may agree
with some of these awards.
Some of you may disagree,
but one thing is for sure
is they're my awards.
So without any further ado,
let's start giving 'em out.
So, the first category is best big phone.
Now, I mean, look at this table.
Obviously, phones have gotten
bigger and bigger over time,
to the point where pretty
much every phone is big.
But I still like to reward a phone
that had a great use of that space
because you still want a big screen
but also a big battery,
maybe big speakers,
some nice cameras, and the whole thing,
just being a good use
of all that extra space.
And so, my winner for the best big phone
of the year actually came out
right near the beginning of it.
And that is Samsung's Galaxy S22 Ultra.
(gentle music)
So hardware-wise, I feel
like this one just pretty
much did it all here.
It's got the big 6.8 inch display,
one of the absolute best in the business.
It added a stylus
but still included a 5,000
milliamp hour battery
which is the same as the year before.
Multiple great cameras on the back,
a pair of great telephotos,
good speakers, good software,
really no hardware flaws to speak of,
to the point where maybe you'd
say it was kind of boring
which I think is actually a good thing.
If you're looking to spend
this much on a phone,
you don't want anything
to be too weird about it.
And so, yeah, this one's the category
in a way that I think the
Notes usually did in the past.
So, it's sort of a return of the Note.
But I do also give some runner-ups
and honorable mentions in
some of these categories too.
And that's what I'm gonna
do in best big phone,
which means the runner-up
is the ASUS ROG Phone 6.
Really similar actually in a lot of ways
to Samsung's flagships, just
missing a couple little things.
It's a little more specialized,
no wireless charging,
but it's got a screen on the back
and it's much more gaming centric.
But I got shout it out
for the incredible, massive
stereo front facing speakers
and also the headphone jack.
Big phone, it should have
room for a headphones jack.
And then also a little shout out,
a little honorable mention
to the Xiaomi Mix Fold 2.
This, it didn't have an IP
rating, it wasn't quite,
you know, available
for everyone worldwide.
But this is one of those folding phones
where it folded just to
about the same thickness
as a normal phone,
which is sort of like one of
those breakthrough moments
in folding phones, I think.
And now we can start to feel like they're
on their way towards being usable.
Big phone, smaller package.
(phone clicking)
All right, next category,
best small phone.
So now, we're on the other
end of the spectrum, right?
There are not a lot of small phones
and this is a rare category.
And I'll be honest, this one wasn't close.
So, last year's winner,
as you might recall,
was the iPhone Mini.
They killed that this year,
so that wasn't even gonna qualify.
So, what would be the best
small phone of the year?
It's the best small phone I've ever seen.
And that is ASUS Zenfone 9.
This phone is so nice
(gentle music)
and they made a lot of great decisions
across the board here.
So, small, it's relative,
but it's a 5.9 inch display,
relatively compact, flagship specs,
Snapdragon 8+ Gen 1, a 1080p,
higher refresh rate, OLED, great software,
tons of ram, really fast, and
a surprisingly great camera.
And if this phone this small
can have a headphone jack,
then what's everybody else's excuse?
Right?
There are a lot of great
things I liked about it.
It did have a couple weird flaws,
like this weird soft touchback
that ended up discoloring a lot.
I talked about that in the main review.
But like, man, I was very surprised
by the battery life on this phone.
There's not a lot of things
I get genuinely surprised
about in the smartphone world now,
but a phone in this small having
such a great battery life,
this is easily, easy, best
smartphone in this size.
But I will give a little
honorable mention,
a little runner up though,
because there was a certain phone
that came out right at
the very end of the year.
You guys might have wondered
why this video was so late.
I'll give partial credit to this one.
Oppo Find N2, this is that
little passport sized phone.
It's got these flat edges and
it's still a folding phone
which has got a pretty
solid display on the inside.
I haven't done a full review about it yet
but it feels like
(phone clicking)
this is a bit of a preview
to what a folding Pixel might look like
which is really interesting.
But all right, let's
get to the next category
which is best camera, or should
I say, best camera system
across the board?
Because there is a lot to a good camera
from photo quality to video quality
but also speed of capture
and auto-focus reliability
and ease of use and file formats
and all this other stuff.
So, we did something really
interesting this year.
We did a blind smartphone camera test
in the form of a website that we built
where we gave everyone the ability to vote
on whatever photos they like
in three different categories.
And we had 16 different phones
from the year all competing
against each other.
And the overall winner
across all three categories
was the Pixel 6A, incredibly.
And actually, runner up
to it was the Pixel 7.
So, these are clearly some
really good photo quality phones
but I'm not giving them the
trophy for best camera system.
I'm also not giving it
to the vivo X80 Pro+
or X90 Pro+, which were low light kings.
They had a really great combination
of software and a really
impressive sensor.
The hardware stack is great, but no,
my winner for best overall camera system
in 2022 is going to the iPhone 14 Pros.
(gentle music)
So, this has now become the
longest defending champion
of a single category ever.
This is the fourth year
in a row the iPhone has taken
down the camera category,
because again, it's
great across the board.
So, image quality as we
know is solid, right?
We knew that.
But the time to open the camera
to actually snap a photo
is extremely quick.
The auto focus is fast.
I'd say, you could fairly
give the Pro iPhones
like an A minus to a B plus for photos.
But then in the video department,
it's a whole different dimension
and it's not really even close.
I've been running the
auto-focus YouTube channel now
for a couple months, doing
a lot of videos on cars,
shot entirely on smartphones.
And you can tell the difference
when I shot a video on the iPhone's camera
versus the other smartphone cameras.
It's how good it looks.
It's the audio quality.
It's the consistency of color.
It's the pro res, the sharpness.
I much prefer shooting videos on iPhones
and I think I'm not alone there.
And I'll say, it still takes a long time
to get the files off of the iPhone
and I hope they fix that.
But it's the winner
for best camera system.
Okay, so next up, let's do the battery.
This is the best battery overall.
I think this is one
of the more objective categories probably,
but it's including a
little more, obviously,
than just the battery size.
I wanna include just
the battery experience,
how long it takes to charge,
how long it lasts on a charge,
battery flexibility of
features and things like that,
how long the battery health does.
And so, my winner
for best battery in a 2022
phone, it is a defending champ.
It is the ASUS ROG Phone 6.
(gentle music)
This one has not a 4,000, not a 5,000,
but a 6,000 milliamp hour battery.
It's got 65 watt fast charging,
so you can go from zero
to full in under an hour.
And on top of that,
there is a bevy of battery
management features.
So obviously, you can
turn the 165 hertz display
down all the way to 60 hertz
if you want to and get a ton of battery.
But then there's also like
charge limit features,
pass through charging, things like that.
This phone is a king
as far as battery life experience
and it actually charges fast.
Probably the only knock against it is
that it doesn't have wireless charging,
which most other phones in
its price range do have.
But as far as just worry-free
battery, that's the winner.
And I will give a runner up
in this category to the iPhone 14 Plus.
So, a lot of us kind of saw this coming
when Apple killed the Mini iPhone
in favor of a plus-sized iPhone
that doesn't have the
promotion OLED display.
So, this is a big, simple 60 hertz display
that is just powered by a
massive battery in the iPhone,
massive four in iPhone.
And so, with wireless charging
and with all the other
things that Apple does
to prevent batteries from having problems,
I'd say that's a pretty
great battery experience.
And I'll also give a quick
shout out, an honorable mention,
because the ASUS Zenfone 9, I gotta,
I keep coming back to this,
the way it surprised me with battery life.
This is a 4,300 milliamp
battery in this phone.
It also doesn't have wireless charging.
The charging speed is decent,
but I was genuinely shocked
by how well this phone held up on battery.
It's, who would've
thought that a phone small
like this would've one
of the best batteries
of any phone that came out
during the calendar year?
But anyway, okay, next
up is the design award.
I feel like this is the
hardest one every year
to think of or to give out,
just because it is the
most subjective now.
This is, it's actually
changed over the years.
It used to be, I think I
called it best build quality
or just best overall build
or materials or industrial design.
But it's eventually
just evolved into like,
who can step outside of the box
and do things a little
different design-wise?
'Cause that honestly
does not happen very much
in smartphones these days.
And sometimes, it kind
of feels like a process
of elimination, like, oh,
I can't give this to a phone
that played it too safe, right?
Lots of phones look basically
the same as last year.
I definitely can't give it to a phone
that made like an obvious regression
from the year before or
has like a glaring issue
with build or materials
or failed, jerry rig,
everything's test or something.
I can't give it to an
iPhone either, can I?
I mean, they still have the biggest notch,
but, oh there's the
Dynamic Island though too.
Maybe, no.
The design award for 2022 is gonna go
to the Nothing phone.
The Nothing Phone won.
Get it?
(gentle music)
The design I think is
literally the best thing
about this phone, maybe second best.
So, it's got this sort of transparent look
which is definitely trying something new.
And then the glyph interface
with these lights on the back,
they light up for notifications.
They can also light up
as a fill flash for video if you want.
It also has a wireless
charging indicator on the back.
It definitely skirts the line
right between gimmick and feature.
Like, a lot of people will get this phone
and have fun with it for a week
and then never use it again.
But I find it really neat.
I think it's cool
that you can see how much
battery is as you're charging.
I don't know, little things like that.
You don't see a lot of
phones trying new stuff.
The rest of the phone happens
to be pretty good too.
So, I have no problem
giving the Nothing Phone
the design award for 2022.
And then I do also want to
give an honorable mention
in design to that Xiaomi Mix Fold 2.
There were a number of folding phones
that came out during this year,
but as I mentioned earlier,
this is the first one that
sort of passed that barrier
of actually being the same
thickness as a normal phone.
I mean, look at,
this is another phone that
came out during this year.
It's very close in overall thickness.
So, a lot of phones you pick up,
like this is Samsung's folding, you,
it just feel, it's thicker
than a normal phone.
And you'd think about that all the time
when you're using it.
So, I wanted to reward this
one for actually getting
to that point where now,
there's other things to fix
still about folding phones,
but this feels very usable and pocketable
and gives you the benefits of unfolding
to a huge screen.
(phone clicking)
Shout out to Xiaomi.
All right, let's give out a value award.
I like this one.
This is,
this was actually pretty
close as well this year too.
Notice it's one of the
more controversial awards.
It used to be best budget phone
but budget means something
different for everyone.
So, I'm just calling this
like best bang for the buck.
You can kind of picture
the pyramid of phones,
and when you see a good one,
you know what I'm talking about.
When you see a phone
that has a great price,
I'm going by launch price, MSRP.
So, the winner, my, I'm giving
my winning by a little bit,
best value award to the Pixel 7.
This phone came out at 599
(gentle music)
and it's one of the best
599 phones I have ever seen.
I mean it's pretty clear.
It's the whole Google flagship experience.
It's also got the tensor chip flagship,
same as the more expensive one.
It's also got the same main sensor,
the same flagship camera
as the more expensive one.
It has a great 90 hertz OLED flat display.
It's so good that it made
the 7 Pro kind of feel
like not that good of a deal
'cause 599, there is not
a lot that you can get
for this price that does this well.
In fact, I'd argue nothing.
So, this is one of my favorite phones
that came out this year,
but it just barely beats out another one
of my favorite phones
that came out this year
which is ASUS Zenfone
9, really unique combo
for this one which launched at 699.
It also now has the Snapdragon 8+ Gen 1.
It's got a ton of ram, 120 Hertz display,
a flat OLED again,
but also like the fingerprint
reader on the side,
a headphone jack and
incredible battery life.
I mean these two phones
could go back and forth
head to head.
I could easily be swayed here.
But those two were awesome to see.
That's probably the best
699 phone I've ever seen.
And among the myriad of other
really good sub $400 phones
that came out, I want to
give an honorable mention
to the Realme 10 Pro+.
This had a big 6.7 inch display.
You can see the cameras on the back,
5,000 milliamp hour battery.
But this camera performed
surprisingly well
to a lot of people.
It ended up beating thousand dollar phones
and it was second place
in votes per dollar
in our blind smartphone camera test.
Really good overall package
for about 350 bucks.
I like the way this launched
and I think if you can get
over the way it shines,
it's a really good one.
All right, bust of the year.
You know, we give it out every year.
You don't like giving it out,
but it's the one you hate to have to give.
You know, there's a lot of phones
that played it really
safe, which is interesting.
And you could argue for
a lot of boring phones
to just have been too
boring, bust of the year,
I wish they did something
more exciting or interesting
but I don't know.
A lot of phones these
days are very similar
to their previous years and
I won't penalize 'em for that
if the previous phone is good.
I really only had one
pick for bust of the year
and that's the OnePlus 10T,
(gentle music)
not a whole ton to say here.
It wins this award for
having a pretty big delta
between expectations and
possibilities versus actual result.
Not all of that is OnePlus's fault,
but I mean they've been on
this slight downward trend
of value and reputation
and software experience
and cameras and a whole bunch
of other things like that.
There's just not a whole lot to like,
and it also just feels
like the identity has sort
of been eroded very quickly over time.
We just had the Hasselblad thing added
to the previous OnePlus flagship phone
and then the 10T comes out
and they don't even bother with it.
I don't know if they're
saving it for the pro phones,
but it's like, what do you, what is this?
What do you even say about
OnePlus phones anymore?
There's no, you can't even
describe a OnePlus phone
without feeling really generic.
So anyway, yeah, congrats on
your award, bust of the year.
So that brings us to the MVP,
the most valuable phone?
Nah, it's not the value award, it's the,
it's my favorites list.
That's kind of what this has turned into.
Like, the best overall phone combined
with the best overall experience,
the best impact on the industry.
There's a bunch of different things
that can float you to the
top of my favorites list
from the smartphones
that came out this year.
And there are a lot of really good ones.
You've just heard about great cameras,
great big phones, great battery lives,
great value, some surprises.
This was a really close
one for me, really tough.
Again, I could be swayed.
I don't even wanna say that about the MVP,
but I really think it's that close.
I have two MVPs, okay?
But I'm giving my top dog,
my number one MVP award
for 2022 to the Pixel 7.
(gentle music)
This phone,
it deserves it for sure.
Like you heard about in its previous win,
great value, okay?
Incredible cameras, great display,
flagship software experience,
really good battery life,
not a whole lot missing.
And that's kind of what you get
with a phone like this,
which is like, all right,
the 7 Pro came out for 300 more dollars.
And that's actually a phone
that I've used a lot to this day.
But what do you really get more for that?
The telephoto camera, the
extra 30 hertz on the display,
like this phone is such a good deal
that it's hard to recommend the 7 Pro.
I love recommending the 7.
It's just an overall excellent phone
and I'm glad that Google
found their groove
'cause I actually just forgot,
I haven't given out the most
improved award yet either.
And that's also the Pixel 7.
(gentle music)
Google really found
their groove with this phone.
And to be fair, there are a lot
of people who might criticize the design.
They don't like, you
know, the visor as much.
I kind of like the glass visor
of the 6 a little bit more
to be perfectly honest.
But I actually like that it's unique.
If you look at a phone from far away,
you know exactly what a
Pixel phone looks like.
From across the street,
you know what a pixel looks like, right?
They're doing this advertising thing.
They're actually getting
into people's hands.
I just did my assistant battle,
and like, the assistant
that runs on this phone,
especially on the Pixel, is excellent.
The voice recorder app,
all the smart features,
hold for me, the screen call feature.
I just, I can't say enough good things.
Pixel 7, great package,
overall, love this phone.
So, why am I so torn?
What is the other phone
that is such a good year
that I have a hard time
only picking one MVP?
Well, it's the Zenfone 9, baby.
This phone, this had a lot
of good things going for it,
and it was one of my favorite phones,
one of my biggest surprises of the year.
Where do I start?
The design I really liked,
despite not having the best
wear and tear experience.
I'm not a big case person,
so I gotta give it a knock for that.
No wireless charging.
But the Snapdragon 8+ Gen
1 had amazing performance.
This phone's battery life was incredible.
It didn't charge fast, but
like I was just amazed by that.
It has a headphone jack.
It has the fingerprint reader on the side
which was very fast
but also had gestures and
surprisingly good cameras.
I mean, these things ended
up top five, top four,
maybe top three in our blind
smartphone camera test,
voted by the masses.
So, ASUS has had great cameras for years.
I just really liked this phone.
It's more expensive.
It was 699 on launch.
I think they did this weird thing
in the US where it launched for more.
But like, if you can get
your hands on this phone
and pop a sim card tray in it
and it actually will work
well with your carrier,
the Zenfone 9 was a very close
second for my MVP for 2022.
But then one more,
I want to give an honorable mention
to the old boring Galaxy S22 Ultra.
It's an expensive phone, it
has all the hardware features.
It didn't really do anything wrong.
It just happens to have one
of the biggest batteries
and the best display
in the business
and one of the best camera
suites in the business
and one of the best processors.
I mean, it's a boring,
really solid overall phone
and that's why it won best big phone.
And so, I'll give it
that honorable mention
because a lot of us wanna see the,
just the best overall phone
of the year highlighted
and specs-wise and what
it does for people,
I think that's a really
good phone to pick,
of course, right alongside
the ROG phone, I could go on.
Lots of great phones came out this year,
but that's been it for the
Smartphone Awards of 2022.
Feel free to leave all the notes
in the comment sections below.
I know all of you guys
will have thoughts on this,
as we do every year.
We'll talk about it.
But of course, if you're
a company seeing this
and you want your trophy, let me know.
Hit me up on Twitter or something.
I'll literally ship it out to you.
I've done that before.
Okay, that's been it.
Thanks for watching.
♪ Talk to me ♪
- Alicia Keys said she
liked my jacket one time.
All right, see you later.
Peace.
(steady music)